hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game uh this one was played in
1976 in belisi and it is uh truly a a
remarkable attacking Masterpiece with
the black Pieces by none other than the
13 year old Gary Kasparov he's playing
against Armenian Grandmaster somebody
putian uh even though he was 19 years
old at the time and he was not a grand
master I just don't have an earlier
photo of him so we're using this one and
it's really really a spectacular attack
we're going to discuss what happens when
we reach that point but it's uh I mean
you will really enjoy this game I know
about it for for quite a long time but
I've just never covered it so I thought
you might enjoy it so luputian has the
white pieces and he opens with the D4 uh
we have Knight to F6 bikers power of C
for G6 Knight the C3 and not Bishop to
G7 because parvo goes for his King's
Indian defense we have Ponte e for end
D6 to going for a standard stuff we have
Pawn to F3 the semish variation against
the king's Indian and did not Knight the
C6 with Bishop to E3 and pawn to A6 so
this is very standard stuff played even
after the at the absolute top level
Queen to D2 and now we have Rook to B8
by Kasparov uh castles is a bit more
frequent here but uh okay Rook to B8 uh
rooked sorry Rook to B1 uh preparing
Pawn to B4 and not as part of castles we
have pawned the B4 grabbing more space
here on the queen side and now striking
in the center Pawn to E5 as you should
the white king is still in the center of
the board so Pawn to D5 Knight to D4 and
now Knight G to E2 aimed at the the
Knight on D4 so C5 by Gary D captures on
C6 upper sound B captures on C6 and now
Knight captures and D4 we have E Capture
Sandy for Bishop captures on D4 and now
Rook to E8 uh getting another attacker
into the game now The Rook nicely
occupies the E file and here Kasparov is
down down upon and he he really wants to
attack that white king but white just
plays Bishop to E2 and is now ready to
Castle so what would you play here it's
a it's a very interesting position
because only one move Kasparov can play
that pretty much gives an equal
possession otherwise white will just be
better if White Castles white is up upon
white has very nice central control
white has a beautiful Bishop on D for
white has already advanced pawns on the
queen side so you have to do something
and obviously that's why a 13 year old
was part of sacrificed upon to get this
position what do you think he had in
mind feel free to pause the video and
try to find a way to maybe start an
attack against the white king while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not allowing
that uh King to to run away and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn the C5 that's how you do
it uh now white uh is forced to react to
this because the bishop on D4 is hanging
I will just mention that this position
was also reached now remember this is
played in 1976 but it was also reached
in a game in 1997 in Denmark and uh here
black just played Knight to H5 and lost
the game terribly little did he know
that he was actually uh in a position
that that has part of brilliantly won uh
in 1976 uh but okay Fantasy Five this is
what has power play so congratulations
to everyone who found this now you keep
the white king in the center at least
for one more move because white has to
react to this and now B captures on C5
that this is the only good way to play
this uh so what did you achieve by by
sacrificing the pawn here well you've
opened up the B5 for your route but now
comes the real shocker of the game and
that is Knight captures on e4 again not
allowing white to Castle as the queen is
hanging so you have to react to this so
F captures on e4 this is the only good
way to accept the sacrifice and danka's
power of plays Queen to H4 with check
and now Pawn to G3 now interestingly
Pawn to G3 is the move that allows
Kasparov to make something out of this
attack if uh White really wanted to
survive white would have to play Bishop
to F2 and then we just trade everything
Bishop captures on C3 Bishop captures on
H4 Rook captures on B1 with Chuck King
to F2 and now of course you have to pick
up the Queen Bishop captures and D2 Rook
cap for sun B1 and D captures on C5 and
you can see that it's uh equal material
uh of course that does not mean it's uh
you know it's an easy game your opponent
is still a Caspar of 13 year old casparo
but still kasparo and you have four Pawn
Islands because power of has three Pawn
Island so yeah you know it is still it
would be very very hard to play this but
okay in the game G3 was played and now
for the second time in this video pause
the video and find the winning idea for
Kasparov while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting This
brilliant line and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on B1 with check and now the
problem is of course The Rook cannot be
captured if Knight captures on B1 then
just Queen captures an E4 and now look
at this The Rook is hanging the Knight
is hanging the bishop is hanging now the
queen and Bishop are attacking it and
there's just no good way to play this if
you move the Rook even Bishop captures
on D4 can be played still the Knight is
hanging and now if you defend the night
the characters on C5 how are you
surviving with your king and E1 and
there's this constant pressure of Queen
captures I need to Checkmate if the
White Queen moves you still have the
bishop pair Bishop the G4 is coming it's
uh I mean this is a dream position so
instead after Rook captures and B1 King
to F2 is played as now kasparov's Queen
on H4 is still hanging and now there is
only one move that Naka spark can play
that wins the game for him and this is
the one that he basically had to see
when he uh played that pawn to C5 move
in order for all of this to work because
without that move you just have nothing
and that move is Rook the B2 that's the
good stuff and now what do you what do
you play if you capture The Rook uh you
you lose terribly just Bishop capture
Sandy four this comes with track and
after King T1 uh Bishop characters and
C3 Queen characters and queen captures
and he for now threatens Checkmate and
also the rook and H1 is singing uh so
there is uh nothing to play here so I
have to Rook the B2 uh all right Le
Putin said let's trade Queens G captures
on H4 okay Rook capture Sandy two and
now Bishop captures on G7 he trades
everything off King captures and G7 and
now King to E3 attacking kasparov's Rook
rooked the C2 and even King to D3 and
this is where because parva has to be
very very careful if he moves The Rook
to B2 tries to save the save material
then uh capturing and D6 with the pawn
will give white to connected past pawns
also there's the E Pawn so this would be
very very hard for
for black to stop however after King to
D3 casparov just plays Rook captures on
C3 and it doesn't shy away from
sacrificing even more material this game
King captures on C3 and not D captures
on C5 and now you have this position
where uh the material is now equal if
you remember because part of sacrifice
the first a pawn for the attack then the
Knight and then he just gave up the
exchange here but white now has four
Pawn Islands because power of has three
Pawn islands and white also has a double
H Pawn so black is definitely better
here uh how will Kasparov play this well
first with Bishop to D3 by luputian
defending the E4 Pawn now bash rip to B7
goes after the E4 Pawn Rook D1 defending
and now we have Rook to E5 uh we have uh
Ponte A4 and now Pawn to F5 now of
course you cannot capture because the
Rook on E1 would hang so Rook to B1 goes
after the bishop and now Bishop captures
on e4 we have rooked the V6 that would
brush on the A6 spawn but now uh Casper
just starts advancing his past Pawn so
Pawn to F4 Rook captures an A6 and pawn
to F3 with Bishop to F1 but now Bishop
to F5 we have rooked A7 with check King
to H6 and now King to D2 now lupusion
has to do something to stop that passed
a F Pawn Pawn to F2 and now Bishop to E2
but now Bishop to G4 Caspar offers the
bishop for the promotion of his past
pawn bishop to D3 and now Rook to E1 now
the F1 square is guarded by The Rook so
F1 Queen is coming if you don't do
anything about it so Rook to F7 guarding
the F1 square and now comes Bishop to F5
only winning move uh but not that
difficult to spot now The Rook no longer
guards the F1 square and you are ready
to promote your Pawn so here A5 the a
pawn the a pawn starts marching forward
Bishop captures and D3 this is even
better
because if you just bring your queen
into the game okay Bishop captures real
captures but you still have the Rook you
still have to deal with the pass Pawn
black would still be winning but this is
just much cleaner because power plays
Bishop captures on D3 Rook captures an
F2 as now the thread is just F to F1
Queen so Rook captures an F2 and now it
seems like Le Putin found a way to stay
in the game because kasparov's Rook is
hanging and also his Bishop is hanging
but even though there's only one move
that again wins the game forecast part
of it's not a difficult one to spot Rook
to F1 and he was in this position unmove
38 that somebody putian resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here now uh okay uh whatever you do
you're not gonna be equalizing in
material you can capture on F1 but then
just Bishop captures and then if Pawn to
A6 you are in time to stop that pawn
bishop captures on C4 A7 Bishop to D5
guards the A8 square and that's it you
will not be promoting that pawn so
really a remarkable attacking game by by
13 year old Gary Kasparov who I mean
look at this he sacrificed upon Bishop
to E2 was played and then he he spotted
I mean look at this combo C5 to open up
the B file then Knight captures an E4 to
open up the Queen's diagonal and the
just you know uh uh set the entire board
on fire Queen to H4 check now okay
Bishop to F2 the game continues but the
G3 a sub-optimal move was played and
then comes everything Rook counters and
B1 King F2 and now Rook to B2 which uh
Kasparov absolutely had the sea when he
played that pawn to C5 move because if
he didn't uh well there's just nothing
for him here your queen is hanging and
your Rook is hanging you you have to you
have to see this so really really a
wonderful one I don't know how it took
me so long to cover this game but uh you
know there are so many games in in the
world that have been played so you know
there are many many more great games
that we still have to cover so keep
suggesting them use hashtag Edition you
can send me an email you can send me a
message on Twitter on any uh you know
pretty much social platform and I will
look into it so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it if you're a
king's Indian player and you didn't know
about this game then I'm sure your day
was vastly improved but even if you're
not maybe you will consider yeah picking
it up or maybe even just you know trying
it in in some of your uh online games I
would like to thank Richard Schwartz and
Jonathan Bradley Christopher Norris
mocosoft and Mikhail arboy for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day